Dr. Saeed Abdul Rahman Mahmoud Maarouf, resident of
Beit Lahiya, pediatrician. I have been working in the hospital for
23 years in the field of pediatrics. I was arrested from
inside the hospital and stayed in Israeli prisons for
45 days under severe torture
and starvation. I was released yesterday, and now I am
at the head of my work at
Youssef Al-
Najjar Hospital, and we did not commit anything.  A
human crime. My weapon is my pen, my notebook, and
my earphone. I did not leave the place. I was treating
children inside
hospitals. I was arrested from Al-
Ahly Hospital in the Australian prisons. The torture was very, very, very
severe.
I am a
doctor. My weight was
only 87 kilograms in 45 days. More than 25
kilograms of my weight. I lost my balance. I lost
concentration.  I lost all
my feelings. We were handcuffed for 45
days. We were handcuffed for 45
days. Description: How much do you describe torture and how much do you describe
humiliation inside prisons? Only those who lived through it will reach the truth.